we're gonna starve to death up here Mr
Morgan
we're okay
we have a few cans of food and a rapid
for what 10 12 people
when I was in the Navy I I do not I was
thinking about the um
the barbecue
what about it that was so good should we
go back
should I think so I'm very up for that
for the record went Tara Black's
Barbecue it was really good
it's really really good oh it's so good
I don't it's funny you take for granted
because I haven't just haven't gone in a
while it's so delicious where do you
usually go
I just go to like restaurants or just
eat at home because it like
I don't know why it's almost like too
delicious but it's like a treat yeah it
should be like a tree but it's not
really not
um it is really special though when you
do have it
like because I feel like it takes a
while to prepare that kind of food yeah
like they're smoking it all day right
and I like it because like when visitors
come and you
go to like Terry blacks and you do the
barbecue and you it's crazy it's so good
and because there's so many like the bar
is so high and then they still deliver
yeah that's cool
and it's consistently great like every
time you go it's amazing
you know one time my dad and I went my
dad used to do his residency here and he
was so excited he was like I can't wait
to go have barbecue I'm so excited
you're gonna live in Texas all the stuff
we ate way too much we got so sick
afterwards
that's the challenge
there's a few Tech
folks here they're really cool they went
out with them but we got trashed like
whiskey just so drunk and what I didn't
realize is when I'm that drunk
the whatever module in my brain that
says don't stop eating was oh yeah
because your body is so relaxed and I'm
having fun and then all of a sudden it's
a good idea to order like 10 pounds of
meat and then you're just well not just
me like everybody together or just eat
eating and just
and it's it's so hard to stop because
it's so freaking delicious and then
you're drunk wait
that's happiness it's delicious yeah
it's great it's great while you're
eating it you know what I've noticed
about unhealthy Foods or like treats
it's always really fun while you're
eating it but before and after
there's always this feeling of like
regrets yeah or like um like before you
eat a cupcake or something I always feel
this feeling of like I'm Really Gonna
regret this after I eat it but I really
want it and then while I'm eating it I'm
like enjoying it I'm like oh this is so
good I want like another one and then
afterwards I'm like why did I do that
yeah
I have to really work on that to walk
away walk away while like do you really
want a thing and you say nope no more
that looks beautiful look at that
do you ski
um I have yeah I did like grew up
cross-country skiing like I'm you know
not downhill
[Music]
I don't know I was born in the it was
born on the on the mountains
the goats no I no I don't I don't really
goats
because they're really good with the
mountains you don't know oh yeah aren't
they the ones that they yeah they stand
on the edges of the oven in a goat oh
yeah what's your best what's your
favorite
really bad meal that you shouldn't be
eating
my favorite really bad meal that I
shouldn't be eating
um
like something naughty uh
probably like fried chicken
I love fried chicken oh I think I've had
much Fried Chicken so talking about like
KFC like no so there's this grocery
store in Miami it's called Publix and
they have the best fried chicken like
it's so good oh like the in like the
little spot that keeps it yeah yep and
it's so good and they have like chicken
tender crispy and all that oh it's so
good
it's great
with sauce of some kind of no sauce I'm
not a sauce person
no I'm not Saucy at all I'm just giving
you respect the people that covers up
with sauce with the people that
by using the saucist 100 the people that
I'll have people here in Texas who are
like
legit barbecue
like aficionados whatever you call that
the selectable they will put sauce on
their bark they'll like dip it and stuff
they'll have like different sauces right
I did that the last time right you did I
put a little bit of sauce
disrespecting the meats it's just not
cool it's like putting ketchup on a on a
steak on an aged I don't judge people
for putting sauce but for certain things
it sounds like a very emotionally
charged with this for anything except
pudding sauce yeah putting sauce in that
barbecue this is the one thing I judge
them on no I don't care but it is I like
I like what am I looking great basic
ingredients
why is it all slow motion uh
the committed Eagle Eye I just don't
know what I'm looking for
this I keep chatting with you thank you
oh shoot
okay all right check it out oh it's
there okay oh cool it has a what is that
it's like a scent what is it
making too much noise
foreign
Woods
we're looking for an animal okay so then
we focus on the track
and then
so all you have to do is press RB while
focusing on the track I just don't know
where the track went oh there we go
so you see how it's like do you know how
do you know we're hunting for an animal
stop oh stop tracking I see
it's a giant TV and the text is blurry
I'm pretty sure my vision doesn't suck
that bad no it's definitely I think it's
just too much stimuli like it's like
just a giant screen you don't know where
to look giant screen a low resolution or
something I don't know what it is
qualities
oh yeah oh yeah
is there any other ones
we get them go get the meat
I don't know how to uncrouch you press
this button
oh okay
let man handle it
I like how you did the hunting and I'm
not doing the Gathering the Gathering oh
hey hey what the
wouldn't it tell me to do stuff with it
no you have to look for more deer
okay